i've already told you multiple times
that big uppercase u is the internal
energy of a system
as really everything thrown in there
it's the kinetic energy of the molecules
it has the potential energy if the
molecules are vibrating it has the
chemical energy
of the bonds it has the potential energy
of electrons that want to get someplace
but for our for our sake especially if
we're kind of in an introductory uh
chemistry physics or thermodynamics
course let's just assume
that that we're talking about a system
that's an ideal gas and even better it's
a kind of a monotonic
monoatomic ideal gas so everything in my
system
are just individual atoms
so in that case the only energy in the
system is all going to be the kinetic
energy of each of these particles so
what i want to do in this video it's
going to get a little bit of mathy but i
think it'll be satisfying for those of
you who who stick with it is to relate
how much internal energy there really is
in a system of a certain pressure volume
or temperature so we want to relate
pressure volume or temperature to
internal energy notice all the videos
we've done up until now i just said
what's the change in internal energy and
we related that to the heat put into or
taken out of the system or the work done
or done to or done by the system but now
let's just say before we do any work or
any heat
how do we know how much internal energy
we even have in a system
and to do this let's do a little bit of
a thought experiment and there there is
a bit and there is a bit of a
simplification i'll make here but i
think you'll you'll find it okay or
reasonably satisfying
so let's say
let me just draw it
i have a cube and something tells me
that i might have already done this
pseudo proof in the physics playlist
although i don't think i related it
exactly to internal energy so i'll do
that here
so let's say my system is this cube
and let's say the dimensions of the cube
are x in every direction so it's x high
x
wide and x deep so it's volume is of
course x to the q x to the third
and let's say i have n particles in my
system n capital n n particles i could
have written lowercase n moles but let's
just keep it straightforward i have n
particles
n particles so they're all
doing what they will now this is where
i'm going to make the gross
simplification but i think it's
reasonable so in a normal system every
particle and we've done this before just
bouncing off in any every which way
every possible random direction and
that's why you know when they ricochet
off of each of the sides that's what
causes the pressure and they're always
bumping into each other etcetera
etcetera and all random directions now
for the sake of simplicity of our
mathematics and just to be able to do it
in a in a reasonable amount of time i'm
going to make an assumption i'm going to
make assumption that one third of the
particles are going
well one third of the particles are
going parallel to each of the axes so
one third of the particles are going
in this direction
are going i guess we could write say
left to right 1 3 of the particles are
going
up and down so are going up
up and down 1 3 and then one third of
the particles are going forward and back
forward and back now we know that this
isn't what's going on in reality but it
makes our math a lot simpler and if you
actually were to do the the statistical
mechanics behind all the particles going
in every which way you would actually
end up getting the same result now with
that said i'm saying it's a gross source
simplification there is some
infinitesimally small chance that we
actually do
fall onto a system where this is already
the case and we'll talk a little bit
later about entropy and why it's such a
small probability but this could
actually be our system and this system
would generate pressure and it makes our
math a lot simpler so with that said
let's study the system
so let's take a sideways view
let's take a sideways view right here
and i have and let's just study one
particle maybe i should have done it in
green
let's say i have one particle
it has some
mass m
and some velocity
v some particle
right there
and what i'm curious and this is one of
the capital n particles in my system but
i'm curious is how much pressure
does this particle exert on this wall
right here
on this wall right here we know what the
what the area of this wall is right the
area of this wall is x times x so it's x
squared
area
how much force is being exerted by this
particle
well let's think about it this way it's
going forward and or left to right just
like this and the force will be exerted
when it changes its momentum i'll do a
little bit review of kinetics right here
we know that force
is equal to
mass times acceleration
when we know acceleration can be written
as which is equal to mass times
i'll just write change in
velocity over
change in
time
and of course we know that this could be
rewritten as this is equal to mass is a
constant shouldn't change and for the
physics we deal with so it's delta we
could put that inside of the change so
it's delta m v over change in time and
this is just change in momentum right so
this is equal to change in momentum
over change in time so that's another
way to write force
so what's the change in momentum going
to be for this particle
it's going to bump into this wall where
in this direction right now it has some
momentum
its momentum is equal to mv
then it's going to bump into this wall
and they're going to ricochet straight
back and what's it what's its momentum
going to be it's going to have the same
mass and the same velocity we'll assume
it's a completely elastic collision
nothing is lost to heat or whatever else
but the velocity is in the other
direction so the new momentum is going
to be
minus mv because the velocity has
switched directions
now if i come in with the with a
momentum of mv and i ricochet off with a
momentum of minus mv what's my change
momentum
my change in momentum off of that
ricochet is equal to
well it's the difference between these
two which is just 2
m
v
now that doesn't give me the force i
need to know the change in momentum per
unit of time
so change in momentum per unit of time
per unit of time so how often does this
happen how frequently
well i have it's going to happen every
time we come here we're going to hit
this wall then the particle's going to
have to travel here bounce off of that
wall and then come back here and
and and hit it again so that's how
frequently it's going to happen
so how long of an interval do we have to
wait between between the collisions
well the particle has to travel x going
back it's going to collide it's going to
have to travel x to the left this
distance is x let me do that in a
different color
this distance right here is x it's going
to have to travel x
to go back then it's going to have to
travel x back so it's going to have to
travel 2x
distance
and how long will it take it to travel
2x distance
well the time delta t
is equal to
we know this distance is equal to
rate times time
or if we do distance divided by rate
distance divided by rate we'll get the
the amount of time we took right this is
just our basic
motion formula so the our delta t the
distance we have to travel is back and
forth so it's two x's
divided by what's our rate well our rate
is our velocity divided by v
divided by
v
there you go so this is our delta t
right here
so
our change in momentum per time
change in momentum
per time
is equal to
two times
our kind of incident momentum because we
get ricocheted back with the same
magnitude but negative momentum so
that's our change in momentum and then
our change in time is this value over
here it's the total distance we have to
travel between collisions of this wall
divided by our velocity so it is
2x
2x divided by v
which is equal to
2 m v
times the reciprocal of this so times
this is just fraction math
v over 2 x what does this equal to the
twos cancel out so that is equal to m
v squared
over x
interesting we're already we're getting
someplace interesting already and if it
doesn't seem too interesting just hang
on with me for a second now this is
the force being applied by one particle
is this force force from one particle on
this wall
force
from one from from particle
now what was the area we care about the
pressure
right the pressure
the pressure
we wrote it up here right we wrote the
pressure is equal to the force per area
right so the pressure is equal to the
force per area so this is the force of
that particle
so that's m
v squared over x divided by the area of
the wall what's the area of the wall
the area of the wall here
it's each side is x and so if we draw
the wall there it's x times x it's x
squared
so divided by the area of the wall
is x squared now what does this equal
this is equal to
m
v squared
over
x cubed right i just divide
you could just say this is times 1 over
x squared when this all becomes x cubed
this is just fraction math so now we
have an interesting thing the pressure
due to this one particle
pressure from one particle
pressure
from let's just call this from the
particle from this one particle is equal
to
mv
squared over
x cubed now what's x cubed
that's the volume of our container
over the volume i'll do that in a big
and a big in a big v
right so let's see if we can relate this
to something else that's interesting so
that means that the pressure
being exerted by this one particle
well actually let me just take another
step so this is one particle on this
wall
right this is from one particle on this
wall now of all the particles we have n
particles in our in our cube what
fraction of them are going to be
bouncing off of this wall that are going
to be doing the exact same thing as this
particle
well i just said 1 3 are going to be
going in this direction one third are
going to be going up and down and one
third are going to be going in and out
so if i have n total particles n over
three are going to be doing exactly what
this what this particle is going to be
doing right
so if i wanted this is a pressure from
one particle if i wanted the pressure
from all of the particles on that wall
so the total pressure on that wall is
going to be from n over three of the
particles the other particles aren't
bouncing off that wall so we don't have
to worry about them
so if we want the total pressure on that
wall
pressure
i'll just write pressure sub on the wall
total pressure on the wall is going to
be the pressure from one
one particle
mv squared over our volume
times the total number of particles
hitting the wall so times
the total number of particles is n
divided by three because only three are
going to be going in that direction
so the total pressure on that wall is
equal to mv squared over our volume of
our container times the total particles
divided by three let's see you can
manipulate this thing a little bit
so if we multiply
both sides by
let's see what we can do if we multiply
if 3v we get p
v
times 3
right
is equal to
m
v squared
times
n
where n is the number of particles let's
divide both sides by n
so we get
p
v
over
over actually no let me leave the n
there let's divide both sides of this
equation
let's divide both sides of this equation
by 2
so we get
what do we get we get 3 halves pv
is equal to is equal to now this is
interesting it's equal to n
the number of particles we have
times
m v squared
over two
remember i just divided this equation
right here by two to get this and i did
this for a very particular reason what
is mv squared over two
mv squared over 2
is the kinetic energy of that little
particle we started off with that's the
formula for kinetic energy kinetic
energy is kinetic energy is equal to mv
squared over
2. so this is the kinetic energy of one
particle
right so this is kinetic energy of one
now we're multiplying that times the
total number of particles we have times
n
so n times the kinetic energy of one
particle is going to be the kinetic
energy of all the particles and of
course we also made another assumption i
should state that i assume that all the
particles are moving with the same
velocity and have the same mass in a
real situation the particles might have
very different velocities but this was
one of our simplifying assumptions so we
just assumed they all have that so if i
multiply n times that this is this
statement right here is the kinetic
energy of the system kinetic energy
of
the system
now we're almost there in fact we are
there
we just established that the kinetic
energy of the system
is equal to three halves times the
pressure times the volume of the system
now what is the kinetic energy of the
system it's the internal energy because
we said all the energy in the system
because it's a simple ideal monoatomic
gas all of the energy in the system is
in kinetic energy
right so we could say the internal
energy of the system the internal energy
of the system is equal to that's just
the total kinetic energy of the system
it's equal to three halves times our
total pressure times our total volume
now you might say hey sal
you just figured out the pressure on
this side what about the pressure on
that side and that side and that side on
every side of the cube well the pressure
on every side of the cube is the same
value so all we have to do is find in
terms of the pressure on one side and
that's essentially the pressure of the
system
so what else can we do with that well we
know that pv is equal to nrt
our ideal gas formula
pv is equal to
n
rt where this is the number of moles of
gas this is the ideal gas constant this
is our temperature in kelvin so if we
make that replacement we'll say that
internal energy can also be written as
three halves
times the number of moles we have times
the ideal gas constant times our
temperature
now i did a lot of work and it's a
little bit of mathy but
these results are one interesting
because now you have a direct
relationship if you know the pressure
and the volume you know what the actual
kinetic you know the actual internal
internal energy or the total kinetic
energy of the system is or if you know
what the temperature and the number of
molecules you have are you also know
what the internal energy of the system
is there's a couple of key takeaways i
want you to have
if the temperature does not change in
our ideal situation here if the
temperature does not change if delta t
is equal to zero
if this doesn't change the number of
particles are going to change then our
internal energy
does not change as well
and so if we know so if we say that
there is some change in internal energy
and i'll use this in future proofs we
could say that that's equal to three
halves
three halves times n r times well the
only thing that can change not the
number of molecules or the ideal gas
cons times the change in t or it could
also be written as three halves times
the change in pv we don't know if either
of these are constants so we have to say
the change in the product anyway this
was a little bit mathy and i apologize
for it but hopefully it gets you it
gives you a little bit more sense that
this is really is just the sum of all
the kinetic energy we've related it to
some of these macro state variables like
pressure volume and time
and now since i've done the video on it
we can actually use this result in
future proofs or at least you won't
complain too much if i do anyway see in
the next video